un sujet pour vous caroline c'est pour
vous lasser étant donné que vous êtes du
genre klepto cleptomane federico berra
s'est levée dans les docks du week end
sur tf1 qu'il s'est intéressé à la
traque des voleurs dont les supermarchés
et dans l'extrait que vous allez voir
c'est un homme qui tente de dérober des
produits tapant le cosmétique sera
caroline après son petit blouson pour
masquer le sac mais là c'est comme s'il
n'avait pas de sac en fait on voit bien
que le blouson cache le sac et on voit
pas du tout il est un sac en dessous
voilà là il prend carrément une boîte
complète de ckoi des gels douche
le voleur n'est pas là pour faire dans
la dentelle il fait le plein
il a vidé complètement le rayon de gel
de rasage n'at il n'y a pas d'état d'âme
la voilà il y va mais on peut
effectivement penser que ça c'est pour
la revente après alors qu'est ce que le
vol dans les supermarchés allan poe
retrait pendant le portrait-robot type
du voleur il a entre 18 et 30 ans vous
êtes pas de temps que s'étonner dans 35
% des cas c'est un homme à 65%
ils veulent de plus en plus pour
revendre et ils veulent surtout durant
la période de noël caroline
évidemment je me tourne vers vous
nettoie qui fait qu est ce que vous
pensez de ce monsieur qui fait des
choses pas très jolies parce que là
parfois on peut dire bah oui mais là
c'était parce qu'il n'avait pas d'argent
c'était pour manger mais là c'est pas du
tout simplement se chausse de choses
c'est pas du tout quelqu'un de ma
communauté
vous avez des ardeurs de ci de là lui va
vraiment trop loin et j'ai été moi-même
très choquée en voyant les images je
m'étonne que finalement ils aient pas
été arrêté parce que moi je vais vous
dire un truc et ça lui ferait du bien de
se faire arrêter parce que ça met à
rêver non plus tard et je vous le jure
dans cette émission que ya une quinzaine
de jours nord effet sécu dlt ou pas j'en
sais rien et c'est même j'avais dépassé
maintenant il ya pas de portrait robot
dans tous les supermarchés c'est
obligerait de gars qui disent que c'est
vrai que je faisais mes courses et je
fais quand même un gros plein de courses
dont se plaint de course il m'est arrivé
ce jour là vous avez d'emprunter un
petit vous savez une petite barquette de
tomates cerises
j'ai mangé effectivement départ de
mémoire de leur label
parce que vous n'auriez des la barquette
de fraises de trucs comme ça c'est
ouvert mais la barquette de tomates
cerises il faut ouvrir le petit capot la
le boulimique dos ça veut dire que vous
avez quand même fait le geste lui ouvrir
le tollé j'ai fait le geste et c'est
vrai que j'ai mangé ces petites tomates
cerises sont trop m'en rendre compte
[Applaudissements]
c'est pardonné et je vais vous dire ce
qui m'est arrivé quand je suis arrivé à
calais en pièces avec la boîte vide
j'espère suffisantes à l'air quel sens
la petite boîte que j'en hypoglycémie un
moment donné dans le magasin c'est vrai
javou j'avoue j'avoue c'est pas bien ce
que j'ai fait pour lui et là j'ai je
suis passé devant la caissière qui à ce
moment-là reçu un coup de fil et
j'entends dire oui oui
ragot dgid à la mutuelle monde d'accord
et là il raccroche et lâche là je viens
de me faire chopper et le vigile
mademoiselle à des histoires comme
personne comme ça vous avez mangé une
boîte de tomates cerises vous avez repos
devant la baguette devant tout le monde
quelque part dans le magasin vous
revenez avec moi rechercher la variance
dans le maillage je vous jure comme mais
la rencontre n 15 mois la pilote qui a
fait une bêtise en match j'avais fait
une bêtise
j'ai vraiment réguler la petite porte
avec les menottes
non je veux pas passer que par des parts
contre je peux vous dire on ne m'y
reprendra plus ça vous attend la
vaccination se faire choisir les fraises
et je je je m'excuse c'est évidemment
pas un comportement à avoir mais sourire
et vous coûte de l'argent mais c'est ce
supermarché quand même nom mais caroline
que ça peut-être mais en ce qui me
concerne moi mon cas personnel
c'était vraiment un petit à petit la
cire canda le oui et d'industrie
l'agencé il en fait c'est quand on se
fait choper conduite est intolérable et
je prenais franchise vous honore je dis
bravo parole
[Applaudissements]
10 caroline et nous intéresse on va pas
applaudir une voleuse même faut pas
charrier vous encourage non moi je n'ai
jamais rien volé mais même pas ne
serait-ce qu'une queue de cerise et
c'est toujours le vigile qui me suit
mais à la trappe
une perle devenue si vous avez une tête
louche je touche vous êtes le challenge
et une capuche des fois une 10 ans lève
ta capuche gimeux pourquoi j'ai
peut-être que vous le voir mes cheveux
enlève ta capuche
avez vous trouvé ben vous êtes suspecte
qu'est ce que voulait dire non mais
quand même je suis jamais roulé tout le
monde est bien d'accord mais donc vous
ne volerait jamais jamais jamais jardin
c'est fini c'est fini je voudrais bien
mais elle a ça dans le sang c'est jamais
fini
[Applaudissements]
si vous allez vous sentir un tout petit
peu moins sept puisqu'on a posé la
question à nos téléspectateurs
est-ce que vous volez parfois dans les
supermarchés sont là peut m'arriver
jamais de la vie
jamais de la vie un 83% ça peut
m'arriver à 16% tout le temps 1 % il ya
dix sept pour cent des personnes qui
sont votre côté caroline et ça vous
savez c'est un non mais c'est mes amis
et je vais leur dire voilà on fait plus
ça on arrête c'est en fait un pacte
entre nous on fait plusieurs rendez vous